Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living.
This episode is brought
to you by four sigmatic,
founded by the Genius Fin's who
lit the Internet on fire and a,
you may have heard of
their mushroom coffee,
which features Chaga and lion's mane,
which has taken Silicon Valley by storm.
I use it pretty much every day,
either that or the Chaga,
which is decaf as a separate version,
and I use both of these primarily
for focus and productivity.
They just get you going let
you up like a Christmas tree,
so definitely check it out.
People are always asking me what I use
for cognitive enhancement and for right
now this is the answer. I try to
force this on all of my house guests.
It is a hell of a thing if
I have employees or people
come over who are working
on projects with me,
I always try to feed it to them because
I'm going to get the limitless effect
and get a lot more out of them.
The first time I mentioned this product
and four sigmatic on the podcast,
their product sold out
in less than a week,
so you may want to check them out soon.
If you're listening to this and
the coffee tastes like coffee,
it takes just seconds to
prepare with hot water.
And oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine,
so it has less than half of what
you'd get in a regular cup of coffee.
I don't get any jitters, acid reflux
or any stomach burn, any of that.
It's very unusual and very,
very cool.
So if you don't like caffeine,
they also offer very strong but
caffeine free mushroom elixirs,
which I will sometimes have
in the evening. I find Chaga
specifically to be very,
very grounding and earthy.
So that is another option.
And I have a cupboard full of
their products, uh, at the moment,
which is right around the corner of
my kitchen. You can try something,
you can try a sample pack,
which is great.
Also right now by going to
foursigmatic.com forward slash Tim that's
foursigmatic,
f,
O u r s I g m a t I c.com forward slash
Tim and use the Code Tim Tim to get 20%
off of your first order and
they're not that expensive. Anyway,
if you are in the experimental mindset,
I do not think you'll be disappointed,
so try them out.
Well,
hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to tease out the
habits, routines, belief systems,
life lessons from people who were the
best of what they do and the to hopefully
give you an opportunity to test
those things in your own life.
And this episode we have
a power couple in fact,
but let's go back in time to around 2009
or 2010 when was given a tee shirt and
the tee shirt was an Avatar as in
the film and Avatar staff t shirt.
And on the front was a quote and the
quote was, hope is not a strategy.
Luck is not a factor.
Fear is not an option.
It is tributed to James Cameron who
is part of the dynamic duo who will be
featured in this episode.
Who's James Cameron.
You ask James Cameron is a filmmaker
and deep sea explorer. He is writer,
director and producer of many films
including the Terminator Aliens,
the Abyss Terminator Two true
lies, titanic and Avatar,
both titanic and Avatar.
The highest grossing film of All time won
the Golden Globe for best director and
Best Picture and were nominated
for a record number of awards.
Cameron was also at the vanguard of the
d renaissance developing cutting edge
three d camera systems as an explorer in
2012 cameras set the world's solo deep
diving record of 35,787 feet in the
challenger deep in a vehicle of his own
design.
He is dedicated environmentalist and
he has founded the Avatar alliance
foundation to take action on climate
change, energy policy, deforestation,
indigenous rights, ocean conservation
and sustainable agriculture.
He's currently in production on
average are two three, four and five.
You can find him on
Twitter at Jim Cameron.
Susie Amos Cameron, his wife is
a noted environmental advocate,
mother of five and the author of o m d,
which is one meal a day.
Omd Subtitle, the simple plant
based program to save your health,
save your waistline, and save the planet.
And the founder of the OMD movement,
a multipronged effort to transform
eating habits and the food system.
She's also a founder of plant power task
force focused on showing the impact of
animal agriculture on climate
change in the environment.
Founded in 2012 with her husband.
That is Jim and Craig McCaw.
In 2005 she founded Muse School,
the first school in the country to be
100% solar powered with zero waste and a
100% organic plant based lunch program.
Additionally,
she is founder of verdant foods,
Cameron family farms and
food forest organics along
with red carpet green dress.
As an actor,
she's been featured in more than 25 films,
including the usual suspects and titanic.
You can find her online. Facebook,
Susie, a Cameron. That's
Susie Suz. Why Twitter?
Suzy musing and Instagram.
Susie Amos. Cameron,
a few housekeeping notes right up front.
There are two other episodes that I'm
publishing simultaneously with James and
Susie on the tribe of mentors podcast.
Want to do an experiment and split things
up a little bit for a whole host of
reasons.
In the shorter episode that you'll
find on the tribe of mentors podcast,
I include their answers to some of my
common questions including what is bad
advice you often hear in your areas of
expertise are in your industry and I'll
give you a teaser for that.
Do what you love is is one of the answers
that is elaborated on favorite books,
books that had been most gifted to
others and then the favorite failures.
So failures they have learned the
most from. And the second episode,
which is going to be on the tribe mentors
podcast is the full audio also not to
be missed,
there's a bonus in text.
So James Mentions in the full audio
that unlike on previous films,
he did not get sick during
the simultaneous filming
slash production of Avatar
two and three, which is astonishing
considering as he put it,
that quote,
they meaning all staff know coming in
when they sign up that it's going to be
the most difficult production in human
history and quotes. So how did he do it?
He credits his stamina and health
during that period to his new routine,
including plant based diet,
supplements, exercise and so on.
So I asked him for a concrete daily
calendar with exact food supplements times
and so on,
which he provided.
So you can find James Super dialed in
daily routine for after our two and three
at Tim dot.
Blog forward slash a James Cameron,
that's tim.blog four slash James Cameron.
All right,
so some of you who are long
term listeners have no doubt,
heard multiple guests on to discuss
the Ketogenic Diet to discuss,
uh,
alternate approaches to food and health.
And I thought that this episode would be
a good opportunity to give some airtime
to discussion of plant based diets.
And it should also be underscored that
there are chapters in the four hour body,
two of them with the legendary ultra
endurance athletes got jerk about plant
based diets and even if
you disagree with uh,
perhaps plant based diets or any of the
arguments you might hear from Suzy and
James that suggest listening for
at least three reasons. Number one,
there's plenty of non plant talk and we
jumped right into it with discussion of,
of how they both respond to
feeling overwhelmed or distracted.
The second is patients.
In this podcast I do my
best to in a gentle way,
sometimes not so gentle,
but often a gentle way,
expose people to different viewpoints,
different perspectives in the world,
which is why I have on
very often for instance,
someone who's highly religious like
rabbi Jonathan Sacks and then I will have
just a few episodes later,
someone like Sam Harris who is phd in
neuroscience and very well known for being
an atheist.
I might have someone who is far left and
then someone who is far right because I
like to focus on some of the commonalities
and also the thought processes.
The only way you can
understand your argument,
your position best is to also
understand the opposing viewpoints.
Or it says number two, this is an exercise
in, especially in these divisive times.
I think it is a worthwhile
exercise. And third, Omd,
one meal per day that is plant based.
Uh,
I would recommend even if you don't plan
on converting to fully plant based as a
consciousness practice and an exercise,
which is something I very often do,
I will, I will impose certain
constraints on my eating,
eliminate a certain food product or I
will insist that I eat based on a spectrum
of color as a way to make my subconscious
or automatic behaviors I eat.
Eating more conscious is that I'm
more aware of what I am doing and the
decisions I am making.
So those are a few of the many reasons
I would suggest listening to this.
And without further ado,
let's just jump right into it
with Suzy and James Cameron.
Well, haul off baby. Well, Tim,
first of all, we want to say hi.
And when we first met you,
we were all flying around and
the parabolic flight with um,
well Ilan Musk and bunch
of other crazy folks. Yeah.
So that was doing somersaults
in zero g super fun.
Super Fun. So, hey Tim, sorry
that's on the show or we're,
we're honored to be here.
Yeah, really, really excited. I guess
you still call a podcast a show?
I guess you can, yeah, yeah,
the Tim Ferriss show. Oh, cool.
Then I guess if it's called the Tim
Ferriss show, then it's gotta be a show
when you feel overwhelmed or unfocused
or have lost your focus temporarily.
What do you do if helpful?
What questions do you ask yourself?
So what do I do when I feel overwhelmed?
Uh, uh, clean off my desk, cause whatever,
I'm working at a high pace, you
know, everything piles up and uh,
just the act of cleaning off my desk,
like a reset.
It's like re it's like power
cycler computer to reboot. And I,
I usually find that about half the
stuff that's accumulated I can throw out
[inaudible]. And the other half I have
to, I have to put in piles, you know,
I have to put them in the right place. So
now I'm prioritizing. Now I'm thinking,
oh well that's, that's still important.
So I think that, you know, the, if you're,
if you're a team leader,
you've got to get your own priorities
straight before you can generate
priorities for the,
for the team.
And I've found that whenever
I hit one of those moments,
I also find it's great to take a
day off, uh, or even half a day off.
Just force yourself to take a
day off, not, not to go play,
but to just reorganize.
Right. And just, you know,
Kinda right now on the series of
priorities are kind of memos to yourself.
And out of that,
I typically will generate things that I
hand out to my team to give them their
marching orders to kind
of get us back on track.
And it's amazing things just pop into
focus and solutions present themselves
because I haven't stopped running.
I haven't gotten off the
treadmill until that moment to uh,
you know, to, to lift my head
out of the day to day battle,
to think about how are we going
to really win this war, right.
It was something like a big film
production is, is, is like a,
a campaign that takes place over sometimes
a period of years. And if you don't,
if you don't take a moment out to
kind of look at the big picture.
So most of the major strategic
decisions that I've made during the,
during the productions of the two avatar
films so far over the last couple of
years have come from that, that
down day, right? That catch up day.
It's not about taking a day off,
taking a nap. That's a good idea too.
And you know,
go swim or play with the kids or
whatever and you've got to do that too.
But just take a day for
yourself with no distractions,
to just get everything in order.
That helps me a lot. If nothing else,
I just feel better about it. Right?
I come in, there's a clean desk,
here's some memos.
You guys go do the work.
Well, I think we're really
similar on that. I mean, I,
I have a tendency to walk through the
House and get ridiculously overwhelmed
with,
you know,
all the kids and the cats and the
dogs and the bearded dragon people.
Yeah. So I always like to go in
and just reorganize the house,
but I always start with my office as well.
And I,
I like to take a big piece of typing
paper and write out, you know,
I create columns and I write out all my
emails that I need to do in all my calls
that I need to do.
And then there's a whole section
in there just for household things,
work things and all of those.
And you know,
I know that the children are learning
this as well because when they,
you know, of course they roll their eyes
when I walk in and say, okay, we're gonna,
we're gonna take a clean day,
an organizing day,
and here's some boxes for giveaways.
They roll their eyes,
but in the end they love it and they
feel better and get into it and they get
into it. So it's, it's, um,
it's the same sort of thing and,
and taking a walk and then realizing like,
okay,
what is the first thing I can do that's
going to get me on that journey towards
my, towards my goal. But always
keeping that goal in mind of,
of whatever that is. You know, sometimes
best way to solve a problem is a
walk away from it for a second. Yeah.
It's counterintuitive for us type type
a types it to bash our heads against the
problem all day long. Boom, boom, boom,
boom. [inaudible] day after day. You know,
I had an epiphany while
I was writing avatar.
It was working down in New Zealand.
Um, office was kind of in the,
in the country and um, you
know, I was just having a,
it was just impossible to solve some of
the dramatic problems. I just couldn't,
I couldn't solve it. I couldn't fix
the script and I was sitting there.
I just walked away. I
sat down, sat outside,
and there was a glass cover to the veranda
and I watched this big fly and he was
trying to get out and he was banging
against the glass and he just kept hitting
the glass over and over and over and over
because that's how his little chip was
programmed.
You go toward the light,
you go toward the sky and
he couldn't get to the sky,
only had to do was drop down,
fly three feet sideways and come out.
But he couldn't process it. And I
thought, how often am I that fly?
How often is there some higher level of
perspective that I lack in my chip that
I'm missing?
That is so simple that some
fourth dimensional being
could look at the problem,
will go, oh you idiot, you just dropped
down. Go over three feet and you're out.
But the fly couldn't do it. And I
thought, what am I not seeing? You know?
And that's when I went back to
first principles and I looked,
I looked at the whole thing from a,
from a higher level.
I'd got out of the trenches for
that moment. And that's how I,
that's how I solved the problem.
I think also too is learning when to
recognize when you're hitting that window
and also learning to recognize when it's
the path of least resistance because
you know you're on the right
path when doors just continue to,
oh well that's true.
That's the opposite. When,
when that's the other thing is important
to recognize when things are breaking
away way when when you have momentum,
when you're not hitting the glass,
you take advantage of it and you,
you ride that tailwind.
There's a difference too. It's,
it's when you know you want
to do something and you
feel really strongly about
it and you have a lot of
people around you saying, no,
oh well you shouldn't do it and
it's going to be too hard and that,
I mean I know it works for you that way,
but I mean that just lights
and Ferno under my butt.
It's like okay really no watch me and I
love to say that to my team on Avatar.
Oh well we shouldn't do that guys.
Cause that's to be hard. Exactly.
When the,
when they know coming in,
when they sign up that it's going to be
the most difficult production in human
history.
Just by its nature where
every blade of grass in,
in, in, in the entire world
that we're creating is done,
is created by somebody,
by a computer artists or by some kind
of algorithm that's self growing or
whatever. You know by definition it's
going to be, it's going to be hard.
You're there because it's hard and you're
doing it because it's hard. You know?
That's because that's how you measure
yourself against that challenge and that's
why everybody's that's on
the Avatar team is, is there,
cause they know it's going to be the
hardest motherfucker they ever work on and
they want that now.
They'll all go whine about it later and
say that was the hardest motherfucker I
ever worked on it and that's why I have
this reputation as a cruel task master.
But in fact they've all showed
up because they want to do that.
They want to climb that mountain
and they've learned from it. I mean,
that's how they're like the teachers
that mute their teaching in a way.
They've never,
nobody teaches
that way and it's really challenging.
But they learn now the kids don't like
holidays because they don't get to go to
school.
If you could have one gigantic
billboard anywhere with anything on it,
metaphorically speaking, getting a
message out to millions or billions,
what would it say and why?
Could be a few words or a paragraph if
helpful. It can be someone else's quote.
Are there any quotes you can
think of or live your life by?
Yeah, I'm terrible with
quotes and that sort of thing,
but I think I would,
I would sum up philosophically
what I would ask people to do,
which is to live in a more connected way,
to see yourself as part of a big global
system and know that every action you
take has a consequence.
Every choice you make as a consumer,
whether it's, you know, using
plastics are using electricity or,
or replacing that,
that iPhone that's only six months
old because there's a better one,
um,
that that has an impact on somebody
somewhere or some animal somewhere or some
ecosystem somewhere that,
you know, um, when I,
when I look at the history of
the human race up until now,
and this all doesn't go on the billboard,
by the way,
I want to try to cut that this down,
but I look at the history.
Up until now we've been all about
expansion. It's an endless hunger to,
to conquer and expand and, and, and, and
we've, we've filled the planet where like,
um, we're like a bacterial culture that
that rapidly expands to the edge of the
petri dish while we're hitting
the edge of the petri dish now.
And so everything that always worked
throughout human history is not going to
work going forward.
We're going to have to have some
fundamental change in the way we think.
We're going to have to stop being takers
and start being caretakers or we won't
survive. It's that simple. Now,
maybe, maybe it's 50 years,
maybe it's a hundred years,
maybe it's 200 years,
but it's not going to go on the way it's
been going on and we're going to have
to change.
And I think it's a change for the better.
It's a change that's more empathic,
it's more compassionate. It, you know.
So I guess I would say stop
being a taker or, or take,
take less and caretake more.
And I mean that very generally as well.
Think about how decisions that you make
and things you do are affecting people
in other, in other countries. You know,
all those people that are coming
up in that big care event,
a lot of them have been displaced by,
by drought.
Their farms have collapsed and they can't
grow there. They can't grow their food.
It's not just about drug violence and all
that sort of thing. Uh, especially in a,
in a water mala, uh, there
are, there are, you know,
hundreds of thousands,
if not millions of people on the move
from farms that have collapsed due to
unprecedented drought.
That's,
that's drier conditions than
they've ever had in recorded. And,
and,
um,
the ability of science to look back
hundreds of thousands of years.
Well that's climate change at work.
And if that particular series of droughts
is not caused specifically by climate
change,
it's a pretty damn good bellwether
for what it's going to look like when
hundreds of thousands and then,
and then ultimately a hundreds of millions
of people are on the move because of
climate change.
So the choices that we're making in our
energy consumption and our consumption
of natural resources in our
consumption of foods is impacting,
um, other people in other
parts of the world. Uh,
it'll eventually come back to haunt us,
uh,
with the kinds of political
systems that are now, uh, you know,
taking over all over the
world, these protectionist,
isolationist, nationalistic,
hyper nationalistic
populist systems that are,
that are about closing borders and
shutting down and all that sort of thing.
I see it all interlink
and I see it all as a,
as a feedback loop that's just
going to get worse and worse.
So I would say we have to change this
from the inside out from the way we view
the world. And our place
in it. And um, so yeah,
stop being a taker. Start being a
caretaker right now. That's my billboard.
Can about the timeline.
The United Nations just came out a
couple of weeks ago with a report.
Um,
and from the IPC saying that we have
to do something by 2032 to turn things
around if we are going
to survive on this earth.
And you know,
one of the things that,
that I really resonate with is the,
the native American tribes, the
first nations, they always say,
no matter what you're doing,
realize that it's going to affect
the next seven generations.
So just being really conscious in your
everyday actions and tread lightly.
Tread lightly on the earth.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean not look,
we all struggle to do it and we're not,
we don't want to come off as holier
than now. That's the thing about,
about vegans in general. As they
all, they're all such, you know,
assholes. Tell your joke. Okay,
how many vegans does it take to screw
in a light bulb? Doesn't matter.
We're better than you. All. Right,
right, right. So, you know, so the, the,
the problem is people tend
to reject, reject what, um,
you know what, we could tell them
all right. But I, I, you know,
I think the answer to that is say,
well don't, don't take our word for it.
Read the books.
It's all online.
The problem is that people
tend to entrench around
their belief systems and now
with, with the, with
digital news the way it is,
we can pre select the inputs,
we can pre select our inputs to
support only what we already believe.
And so everybody lives in these,
in these kind of isolated echo chambers,
you know,
and it's all exacerbated by,
by social media and so on.
And so it's really going to be another
thing that we're going to have to just
get a whole lot better at as a,
as a species and as a society is checking
our facts and looking at alternative
opinions and especially look at the,
at the facts that the, that the,
that the other guys have,
if to have any,
yeah.
I just did a little calm from confirmation
bias swerve at the end there. Yeah.
If the avenue,
yeah. Right. Exactly. Um, alright,
so next question.
What are you currently most excited about?
Um,
all right.
I'm not going to talk about about plant
based nutrition other than to say for
one second that I was pretty hopeless
about being able to get a handle on
climate change.
Just looking at it from
an energy perspective and
transportation and all that.
And,
and when I realized the environmental
connection from eating plant based,
I got excited about that.
But that's kind of old news because
that's six years ago for us.
I guess right now I'm excited
about the Avatar films I get,
I have the coolest job in the world.
I get to go in and,
and create a world and ecosystem populated
with creatures and cool characters
and do that all day long and uh, you
know, live in that fantasy world.
So yeah,
I'm pretty excited about it.
Yeah. So just to piggy back on, you know,
feeling hopeful because I am going
to talk about plant based eating. Uh,
Jim actually has a t shirt and one
of the lines on it says hope is not a
strategy. And um, he's
a doomsday kind of guy.
He watches movies,
they're kind of like the end of the world
apocalyptic and he never used the word
hope.
And six and a half years ago we were
walking on the beach and he said to me,
for the first time in my life, I
feel hopeful. And needless to say,
I almost, you know, fell into the surf,
but it's planted a seed, you know, that,
that the more people we can
inspire to eat, plant based,
the more we can move the
needle on climate change.
And it was that seed that was planted
that made me think about creating content
and writing a book.
And I'm most excited about about the book,
about my book and MD changing
one meal a day for the planet.
And it starts out with the
education of the health.
I worked with a brain trust of doctors,
so it's very,
very heavily researched in the medical
field around plant based eating.
And then I worked with people from
Chatham House and Oxford University in La,
Loma Linda,
climate scientists to help me with the,
the environmental impacts of animal
agriculture. And then it's a guide.
It's a guide of how to do one
meal a day or two meals a day,
or blow up your kitchen
like Jim and I did.
And go cold Turkey as recipes,
shopping lists, meal plans,
and I'll hold your hand.
I won't judge you. It's,
it's not about being perfect.
You can keep your burger if you want to.
It's just about one meal
a day. Oh, M d. Right.
So I think there's one more question
there is one more question. Um,
if you had a request,
an ask or suggestion for the listeners
of this podcast, what would it be?
Oh,
I think people that listen to,
to Tim and his guests are looking for
a hacks to make their life better,
uh, to, to learn how to live in
this, this perplexing world and, and,
and live better and kind of be
smarter. So I think that, uh, you know,
I would just say, read a lot,
check your facts. And, uh,
you know, don't, don't, don't follow us
because we're so sweet and compelling.
Check the facts.
Just the facts ma'am.
Yeah, I mean, you know, it's
all out there, but I would
say also take to take the,
uh,
be willing to look outside
your confirmation bias bubble.
And I, I like, I,
I forced and challenge myself to do
this all the time to get outside that,
to get outside that bubble. Um, and so,
you know, whatever your beliefs are,
ask yourself one where they came from,
when did you double down on that and
what have you done to look at it sort of
from an objective point
of view. Um, and you know,
I tried to do that as much as possible
and then something comes along that I
don't understand that doesn't fit my
belief system. Like, uh, you know,
let me just give an example.
Like Allan Savory's approach to
regenerative agriculture with, you know,
grass fed beef and all the claims
that were made around that.
I looked into it and I thought,
wow, maybe there's something here.
And I went pretty far down the
rabbit hole on that before and,
and looked at the science on,
on both sides of it and ultimately
saw that it wasn't the right answer,
but uh, but I didn't just reject it
out of hand because it didn't fit my,
my, you know, my belief system. Right.
Well I think my ask would
be to take the OMD pledge,
they pledge one meal a day or two meals
a day or go all in because it will help
your health and it'll help the
planet. It'll help your, the animals,
your waistline and your sex life. Yes,
yes. Not necessarily in that order.
Anyway. Um, thanks Tim. This was,
this was really fun and for having us on.
It's been a pleasure.
Thank you. Yeah, thank you.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share
the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to a four hour work week.com
that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought
to you by four sigmatic,
founded by the Genius Fin's who lit
Internet on fire and you may have heard of
their mushroom coffee,
which features Chaga and lion's mane,
which has taken Silicon Valley by storm.
I use it pretty much every
day either that War II Chaga,
which is a separate version and I use
both of these primarily for focus and
productivity. They age get you going
let you up like a Christmas tree,
so definitely check it out.
People are always asking me what I use
for cognitive enhancement and for right
now this is the answer. I try to
force this on all of my house guests.
It is a hell of a thing if
I have employees or people
come over who are working
on projects with me,
I always try to feed it to them because
I'm going to get the limitless effect.
It's a lot more out of them.
The first time I mentioned this product
and four sigmatic on the podcast,
your product sold out in less than a week,
so you may want to check them out soon.
If you're listening to this and
the coffee tastes like coffee,
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine,
so it has less than half of what
you'd get in a regular cup of coffee.
I don't get any jitters, acid reflux
or any stomach burn, any of that.
It's very unusual and very, very
cool. So if you don't like caffeine,
they also offer very strong,
but caffeine free mushroom elixirs,
which I will sometimes have
in the evening. I find Chaga
specifically to be very,
very grounding and earthy.
So that is another option and I have
a cupboard full of their products, uh,
at the moment, which is right
around the corner of my kitchen.
You can try something. You could
try sample pack, which is great.
Also right now by going to
foursigmatic.com/tim that's four Sigmatic,
f, O, u, R, s, I, g, m, a, t, I,
c.com/tim and use the Code Tim Tim to
get 20% off of your first order and
they're not that expensive anyway,
if you are in the experimental mindset,
I do not think you'll be
disappointed to try mine.